I interviewed Sam bankman freed and he
hated it so much that he left within
minutes in part because he didn't know
he would be interviewed by me he thought
he was being interviewed by someone else
on Twitter and I snuck up in the DMS and
got on the call and started peppering
him with some harder questions and
within minutes of that um suddenly Mr
open and honest decided he needed to
leave but I didn't let that stop me
because I joined an interview the very
next day doing the exact same thing
ambushing him again and I got some
pretty good answers out of it I think
the running theme Here is with this
whole press tour he's going with this
image of you know I'm embarrassed I made
a mistake but I'm here to be open and
honest now but that's not true because
when you actually hit him with some hard
questions suddenly meetings come up
Suddenly he can't talk suddenly he's
just Mr ums and oz so I wanted to show
both interviews I think they're very
interesting I really wanted to press him
on this eight billion dollars that
mysteriously went missing that he didn't
know about and I'm sure I'm going to be
breaking these down more specifically in
the days to come but for now I just want
wanted you to enjoy these unedited
conversations with Sam bankmanfried that
he didn't know he'd be having uh coffee
Zilla the mic is yours man hey thanks
for having me
um I just wanted to quickly ask so
there's this big question about this
eight billion dollars that went into
some kind of a stub account if I just
want to get some clarification on this
from my understanding what you're
basically claiming is is that back when
FTX didn't have banking you'd use
silvergate through to have people to
wire money to Alameda research
and then credit them on the FTX side but
you didn't actually account for that
money going back to them so essentially
you had like eight billion dollars
coming to FTX you didn't have on the
book technically I mean how can you
explain more how that worked because it
seems like such a key part of this whole
thing and so far we've gotten like very
vague things about stub accounts just
try to be as specific as you can on how
that actually happened
so
um I so and again some of these are
things I'm trying to piece together that
I don't have the full answer to but
um uh but I think that part of it was I
believe that there was
um you know uh correct FTX accounting um
in terms of you know the audit
financials
um but
um I but that at least I can say that
when you sort of pulled up
um you know on a dashboard what uh what
you know the accounts look like
um uh it would not have I it wouldn't
have uh displayed
um you know those transfers and it
wouldn't have displayed the balances
related to those uh which meant that it
was
um that the sort of what you would
naively see as the relevant
um uh you know it's the relevant uh sort
of position size was quite a bit smaller
than what the full position size wise
specifically you're talking about the
funds that went into Alameda that was
credited to Ft on on the customer side
on FTX you're saying you're saying that
basically when you looked at your
dashboard Alameda was using those funds
to trade perhaps but that ultimately you
couldn't see that on the Alameda side
because there was some kind of an
accounting problem where there was a mix
up with where it was credited is that
the story
yeah it's something roughly like that or
at the very least that the the this the
the common displays of it did not
um did not just did not include that
piece of the accounting a real quick
second follow-up
um so I've talked to a few Alameda
insiders and I've kind of run them by
your uh story of things I think you
probably are aware I'm pretty skeptical
um and they one of them when I told them
like sort of like could it be that Sam
wouldn't know about this somebody who
worked with you and they actually like
they laughed and they said there's no
way he's like he's like claiming to be
stupid now when he was like this genius
Wonder kid and so my sense of things is
how do you explain this how do you
explain the fact that your some of some
of the people who worked with you for
years your employees have come out and
said there's no way he didn't know about
these back doors there's no way he
didn't know what Caroline was doing when
you guys were very close the office is
we're right next to each other I mean
how do you expect us to believe this
story you're spinning
I I don't know what to say likey I I had
a lot going on
um and I was spread thin I was a bit
less grounded than I had been before
um and I lost track of a lot of
important things and I I mean I think
that
hang on one second I think spread thin
is one thing right like I think you know
things can get out of hand but we're
talking about a fundamental
understanding of whether Alameda was
co-mingling funds with FTX I mean I saw
your Stephanopoulos and Sorkin interview
and you're pretty categorical that you
had no idea that you were mingling fun
so that's what I'm asking about not like
did you know exactly what was happening
on November 7th or 8th I mean I can
understand sort of things getting out of
control but we're talking about the most
fundamental grasp on how your business
Works you're telling us you had no idea
I was not aware of a lot of what was
going on I was vaguely aware that some
of these systems existed
um I know details of them and uh and I I
you know was not spending much time uh
and on uh looking at you know position
risk management it was a big mistake
I mean you're right Sam I've just got so
guys guys I've just got a DM of Sam Sam
has to has to leave so guys
uh so yeah I I have a couple questions
read the margin account I mean um
there's sort of all this talk about the
terms of service did you break terms of
service did you not you're basically
claiming that there was a separate side
of your terms of service which said that
uh if people had margin accounts you
could use kind of their funds or there
was looser language around that but I
talked to somebody from Alameda and
asked how big the position of like or
how many people had assets in the type
of accounts that that terms of service
would apply to versus the regular terms
of service which said you couldn't use
their money and they said it was about a
billion that was in the margin trading
or the the margin like uh
side of things where you could reuse
their funds or whatever and there was
the rest of it was not there so does
that mean the rest of the money was
stolen I mean like it seems like you're
putting all your eggs behind this one
excuse about you know there was this
separate side of the terms of service
how do you address everyone else
so I don't have all the day in front of
me my memory is that it was
substantially more than a billion
um in the margin trading program
um but I don't have that day in front of
me right now so I can't verify that
um on top of that there were other
effects as well
um and I don't have the data about all
the details of those in front of me but
my understanding is that
um you know some of those were uh you
know uh early uh wire transfers sent
directly to Alameda which I think
contributed to the position as well
um and then their open Futures positions
on top of that you know on top of the
spot margin positions
um where uh you know there can be
effectively socialized uh you know
losses clawbacks if you know one is
unable to be closed
um uh in time and so I think it was a
combination of those factors
um
uh there may have been other factors too
but that's what I've been you know able
to to piece together
um and that you know putting those
together
I think he is is likely how you got
um to most of this but
um uh
but here's the thing how do how do you
account for maybe the difference in what
people are hearing from insiders uh who
are not being accused of Fraud and you
who sort of is there's a very different
sort of story going on here where you
you know you're saying like oh there's
this big position that we didn't know
about because you told me that the last
time we spoke in a space and I went and
followed up and I said hey is this true
could it be that this uh you know number
just wasn't known about
and some Alameda Insider said no way you
could see on dashboards really simply
where it was and FTX dashboards not
Alameda dashboards dashboards that you
yourself had access to so my question is
sort of like
it seems like when I go to Alameda
insiders or FTX insiders they're saying
this story makes no sense but when I go
to you who sort of has every incentive
to sort of lie and obfuscate
um because obviously the incentive here
is well otherwise you might go to jail
uh which obviously would be a very bad
thing for you
it seems like all of a sudden all the
excuses come out and then when we follow
up on them they don't seem to be true so
I I don't know like help me Square this
because you know it'd be nice if you
were telling the truth but everything
we're hearing from insiders is that
you're not
I don't know what to tell you I'm saying
what I believe I don't know which
insiders you're talking about I don't
know exactly what they said it doesn't
line up with my beliefs but I can't
speak to what they think or what they
said
but why are multiple people within your
company at less senior roles knowing
more about the company than you
and almie was not a company that is
running at the time but I hear you I I'm
sorry I I don't know exactly what you're
referring to I don't know who you're
talking about I don't know what they
said
um I don't well I'm telling you what
some of what they said I mean for
example one of them was that there was
like that like that back door system or
whatever a that you knew it existed and
B that it was easy to see the balance or
the the position of Alameda very simply
on FTX dashboards
because they had a they had a margin
trading account with you guys so you
guys could have seen it but you guys
could see the margin positions of
everybody no but a lot of the decision
did not appear in that main account
so where was the position
it was in a separate sub account I
believe related to wire transfers that
had been sent you know to Alameda
research uh generally primarily to FTX
um having its own bank accounts
so who controlled the secret stub
account
I
did anyone at Alameda know about this
secret stub account I mean are we
supposed to believe that just like there
was this stub account that nobody knew
about
I don't know who knew about what when
I'm sorry
I mean clearly somebody lost the money
right like obviously the money went
somewhere somebody lost it it just seems
really convenient that eight billion
dollars was located in this like account
that didn't show up when you pulled up
alameda's balances right
yeah I I don't know what to tell you
um okay so a separate question is
obviously around this Forbes thing
because you've said you don't have you
don't have present knowledge of sort of
like alameda's balances and they came
out and said that you were giving them
up-to-date balances from Alameda how do
you square that just as of a month ago
you knew um alameda's position how does
that swear with your statement about
like you don't know what's going on I
haven't seen the the thing that you're
referring to but I was able to give very
rough approximations that included a
subset of the list of assets
that Alameda had
um I by asking about the assets I
believe to be the largest sets of them
um I was not giving you know full
accountings
um I of all of alameda's balances or
positions
um because I you know didn't generally
have those and because it was it was a
complicated process dependent on
liquidity of tokens and things like that
from the Ford's perspective so I was
just sending them a sort of abbreviated
partial list of Alameda assets
periodically
but that means you knew that what what
Alameda had even roughly you knew what
Alameda had
I had a rough sense of what their assets
are that is correct
um by rough I I do mean to within you
know 10 billion or so
um I did not have a fine grain sense of
what their asset total asset value was
and I did not have a fine-grained sense
of their liabilities or if their margin
position size or how that was split up
I guess one of my questions is like what
do you think
should be done if we find out that
you're lying about all of this like sort
of because it's kind of one thing to to
steal people's money it's another thing
to lie about it what do you think should
be done like because I I mean it's gonna
be obviously a lot of this is gonna
eventually get litigated uh you know
eventually Caroline Ellison's gonna have
to take the stand what happens if she
pulls out text messages that shows you
knew about it I mean do you think that
wipes away your credibility
I mean I think a lot of my credibility
has already been wiped away frankly and
I think that's honestly that's not what
I'm thinking about right now I'm not
trying to focus on you know when I like
I'm just thinking about
like customers or who I think are are or
what matter
so you're saying there's a chance for
them to get money back or for us to get
our money back
I don't want to speak out of turn and I
I can't make promises on behalf of the
company I can't speak on behalf of the
company
um and I don't know what decisions
everyone's gonna make
um I do know that FTX us to my knowledge
is totally solvent and could I think
um return everyone's money tomorrow if
it wanted to
um and I think internationally uh you
know there are a lot of Pathways you
know potentially for there that one
could imagine
um FTX International taking I think you
know I know that as of before I filed
um there were billions of dollars of
like serious funding uh offers
potentially on the table and
um you know I would I would uh expect to
hope that those are being people who are
those funding offers
I I don't know that I have uh authority
to uh well you said you had four billion
dollars like that came in right yep is
that still does that still exist was
that ever real
uh I think it uh I mean I think it I I
don't know for sure but
um I think that some of those might
um it I I my guess is that that some of
them might that and
um I you know
I I hope that the serve relevant teams
are doing whatever they can to maximize
value for customers here
yeah it just kind of doesn't make a lot
of sense why someone would pour four
billion dollars when you guys have
liabilities sort of as high as you do
um can you talk a bit about the marked
um The Marked market like statements you
were making around solvency you're
making some pretty outrageous statements
about like FTX you know had the money
when a lot of it was serum ftt these
tokens that you know you can't sell in
those amounts and you know that would
completely crash the price they can't
support that kind of selling
um where you kind of deliberately
misleading people there
so I what I can say is I was just
thinking about them in terms of well uh
you know their Mark Price was just
whatever their market price was at the
time and you know obviously I was
cognizant of the fact that
um uh that
you know you can't
the the market price isn't necessarily I
mean is is never you know what you could
sell a large amount of of something for
but I also massively misjudged that
discrepancy there and
um uh what what do you mean you
massively misjudged it because you knew
sort of roughly the percentage of of
serum and ftt you held
and you knew the the trading volume I
mean you are a smart guy you're a
professional Trader you know there's no
way you make a simple mistake like that
right like how how's that even possible
I mean
was a pretty big misjudgment and
mistakes that I made
um and a pretty embarrassing one but I
was thinking if it internally in the
context of Standard Market environment
and obviously that still means you know
substantial impact but uh but it's a
different scale than what you would see
um than what we did see in the market
crash that happened where
um without selling uh you know without
liquidating the position there was a you
know
much larger than 50 market crash in a
few day period
um with you know uh very little mid-side
liquidity and I
you know that obviously
history has said again again that those
events are possible those very
correlated Market crashes and not just
very correlated Market crashes in those
instruments but once were Hedges don't
end up working fully or even right but
we don't we don't even need to to have
this market crash for the statement
about Mark to Market uh accounting
making no sense right and you just said
that yourself even with with standard
movements right if you tried to sell the
amount of serum or FDT that you had on
the books you wouldn't have gotten half
you wouldn't have gotten a quarter of
what you put on your books to investors
and so the question is is like we know
that you're not the problem is is like
every time it comes to this hard point
the answer seems to always be I made an
embarrassing mistake but at what point
are you gonna say like no I'm a smart
guy right you were you were at the
highest levels of this entire industry
you were the guy to go to the smartest
guy in the room right it's hard to
believe that you made this many
embarrassing mistakes one embarrassing
mistake I get it but you're just
everything's an embarrassing mistake at
least tell us that you knew that the
mark to Market made no sense
and the way that I was thinking about
risk at score was starting with march
Market and then adjusting down
effectively from that
um and uh and obviously that means that
there should be a real buffer because of
exactly what you're saying that buffer
should have been a lot larger than I was
thinking but you never you never you
never went you never went down from risk
from there and you said publicly you
said
FDX is solvent other views May differ
well there is no other view on it
there's the fact of how markets work and
you are making public misleading
statements it wasn't one time you did
this you continued to make misleading
statements about it after people have
had given you pushback so which which
times are you talking about here I think
it was in one of your follow-ups about
the what happened you uh you said
something about other views May differ
oh that was ftxc us was it not
I'm gonna look it up real quick
I got a quick question about
um Dan Friedberg your Chief regulatory
officer this is a guy uh so obviously
one I I I don't feel comfortable like
talking about other people without
getting you know sort of there sign off
on that so I I think there's a limited
extent to which I'm gonna be willing uh
or or feel comfortable
um you know speaking on others behalves
no that's totally fair and I don't want
you to speak on his behalf obviously I
want you to share your perspective your
unique perspective on the situation
um just like the same I might ask a
question about Caroline Ellison but I
only could expect your position on the
situation so kind of the um the the
situation there is obviously this is
sort of a tale of two stories about how
FTX failed one is like a lack of
Regulation a lack of clarity of the kind
of just this thing that accumulated over
time the other one is of course the
story of fraud of course we have to look
at who are the adults in the room one of
the adults obviously was Dan Friedberg
Chief regulatory officer
um I'm sure you're aware he was behind
the um ultimate bet Scandal where he
gave players god mode in a poker game
where people could see
um the hands and he actually like
basically conspired with Russ Hamilton
to hide that so does that suggest
something about your intention that you
hired a guy that basically one of his
biggest achievements was hiding fraud
um can you explain sort of your thinking
I know you don't want to talk about him
can you explain you're thinking about
why this would be the guy you choose as
the chief regulatory officer
um
I mean we had a number of people uh in
the
legal department uh we had that was you
know maybe our fastest growing
Department
um we had a number of outside law firms
as well you know Dan was obviously one
of the people who had been you know
working uh you know for fkx for a while
he was yeah he's the chief guy he should
have caught some of this stuff you'd
think in theory well when you say he's
the chief guy I mean there's you know we
also General counsels we had we had
other positions as well but
um uh but uh you know I I can't speak to
what
other people's you know views were what
they thought or knew or were intending
when
um but I you know I know that like
our our you know legal and Regulatory
team had an enormous task in front of
them we were looking to get you know
licensed and regulated in dozens of
jurisdictions at once we did end up
doing that that was an unbelievably
large undertaking which I think you know
took up most of the time of you know
most of our legal Reliance departments
and you know in retrospect I think you
know probably took up too much time
um uh but at the end of the day I was
CEO and that means that at the end of
the day it's on me to make sure that we
have people who are in charge of you
know all the important things and I did
that for some of the areas I failed to
do that for others and but why'd you
choose him specifically I mean obviously
you could have chosen a lot of different
lawyers to go with and I understand you
had multiple lawyers but if this is if
this story of FTX is largely a failure
of regulation of failure of controls at
an organization and your Chief
regulatory officer is Dan Friedberg the
question is well maybe this wouldn't
have happened if you hadn't put a guy
like this in front of this I'm not
obviously saying it's his fault solely
but I'm just asking sort of what was the
thinking behind putting this guy in
charge because it seems like you
couldn't pick a less qualified candidate
if you want to get actual regulation in
the room
I'm pretty con I I didn't say this is a
failure of
regulation and we did an enormous amount
of work on you know getting licensed and
regulated we're licensed in more
jurisdictions than I think any other
exchange was
um I think it was absolutely a failure
of oversight of risk management
um
um but uh
uh but you know and I think that you
know
in retrospect I would have viewed the
core duties and things I I needed to
make sure more so than anything else
very differently than I did
um but I but from a you know becoming
licensed perspective
uh we did do quite a bit there and were
um able to accomplish that and you know
in Fairly short period of time and so I
I think I'm not sure that I completely
agree with the premise of
um of that for me the question and you
know I'll just say that like the people
who work with FTX like
I have enormous respect for most of them
and they you know did enormously
valuable work and
um you know they didn't do all the work
obviously they're really important
things that didn't get done
um but that's on me as CEO to make sure
that there are people who are doing all
the important things because there's way
too much to do we're doing way too much
as a company for
um you know any particular person to be
expected to be definitely on top of even
if some important things
um given how many other important things
they also had to be dealing with at the
time
um so and by the way I do apologize I do
I am fairly late at this point for next
thing I do have to to hop off
Sam thank you so
much time and coffee Zilla and other you
know speakers thank you so much Marty
everybody thank you so much